foreign
Kalamazoo Michigan hi Jane welcome to
the Ramsay show
what's up well um I I've been listening
to you for a little while now and you
seem to favor a Roth IRA over a
traditional IRA quite frequently I know
the differences
um I'm wondering why you tend to favor
the roths and I could tell you why my
financial advisor originally put all my
money into a traditional if you want to
hear that
well tradition uh it's possible that
your financial advisor fell in the same
hole that other financial advisors fell
in uh and couldn't get out and that hole
was the the in order for the traditional
to work out ahead of the Roth
mathematically you have to be in a lower
tax bracket dramatically at retirement
than you are now a dramatically lower
tax bracket which by the way means you
haven't got any money
because if you've got five million
dollars your required minimum
distributions at 70 and a half are going
to put you in the same tax bracket
you're in now
so you're not going to be in a lower tax
bracket and so the Roth absolutely
mathematically kicks the traditionals
but
and here's why if you take 200 a month
from age 25 to age 65 40 years and you
invest that in a decent growth stock
mutual fund you're going to have two and
a half million dollars in there however
only 96 000 of the two and a half
million is actual
principle that you put in so if you did
a traditional in that you would have
gotten a tax break on ninety six
thousand dollars you would have not paid
taxes yet on 96 000 but you'll pay taxes
on the entire two and a half million as
you pull it out if instead you did this
with a Roth you would pay taxes on the
96 000 and zero taxes on the rest of the
two and a half million
so there's no way
that the traditional even comes close to
the Roth mathematically does that help
you
my must be why my financial advisor went
that route because yes when I was I'm
retired now but when I was making a
decent salary
um he I wasn't obviously in a higher tax
bracket than I am now that I'm retired
and so um he's moving slowly every year
a certain amount from the traditional
into the Roth to still keep me in a very
low tax bracket no that's good that's a
smart that that is a smart move but he
assumed that you weren't going to have
enough at your required minimum
distribution because you know in my
example you got a tax write-off on
ninety six thousand dollars and then you
still end up paying the taxes on it when
you pull it out later
and so it just doesn't make sense at all
now um when Ross first came out they
really took the nerd population of
financial planners and blew their brains
out I mean they their minds they just
were in a hurricane they didn't know
what to do and I was one of them I spent
numerous hours crunching numbers trying
to figure out this thing and and here's
the other interesting thing George is
when you compare apples to apples
what we would all do in those days is we
were trying to do the proper math
calculation so if you're going to say
all right a hundred dollars going into a
Roth
requires because you've got to pay taxes
that's net of taxes so to put a hundred
into a Roth you actually have to make
130.
right yes so we would say all right 130
going into a traditional or a hundred
going into a Roth because that's a
correct set of mathematical assumptions
for a math nerd and if you're a
financial planner you usually are super
math nerd right now here's the problem
with that that's not what people do
regardless of the tax situation that
they forget that taxes have already come
out I've already got the taxes out of my
Roth but I'm still going to fully fund
the eight thousand dollars to six
thousand dollars right yeah I'm gonna
still Max the thing out I'm still going
to put the exact same percentage of my
income into the Roth 401k at my work
even though there's it's net of taxes
it's it's I mean it took more money to
get that in there yeah than it did to do
that in traditional but no one ever goes
you know I'm going to put 80 into my
Roth instead of a hundred into my
traditional they don't reduce it they
just put the same amount in yeah and so
you end up with a Roth we cheat you we
trick you into saving more by accident
you didn't even know it no one no one's
called in saying Dave I did Roth like
you told me to I got too much money in
retirement what do I do I've never had
anybody no I followed your plan on on
getting a match first and then getting
all the Roth I could get and then doing
traditional and I ended up with millions
of dollars and I hate Dave Ramsey I have
never had had that complaint
no and on top of that there's no
required minimum distributions on the
Roth IRA so that's a big bonus as well
and when I get to retirement I don't
want to be worried about tax brackets
and how much income I can withdraw I
just want to live and give like no one
else and not have to worry about that so
Jane where you have ended up today
you're getting good advice on the
gradual move so as not to bump your tax
bracket because whatever you pull out
from under the traditional move it to
the Roth is not going to be subject to
require minimum and it's going to grow
from this point forward tax-free but
you're not you're doing you're moving it
gradually so as not to bump up a tax
bracket and that's good advice the
advice that got you here however is a
bad advice
you should I wish you were all in Roth
right now you'd be in much better shape
you wouldn't have any of this discussion
going on and you probably have more
money so but but it's not the end of the
world you did good and you've retired
you got a chunk of money and you know so
you and I got the opportunity to talk
theory and that's awesome I love it I
love it I love it I love it so the rule
is rock paper scissors but except
there's only one way to go okay
match
beats Roth
a hundred percent match before you get
started you can't beat you can't beat
that math right
beats Roth Roth Beach traditional so do
all the mats you can all the Roth you
can and only then do you do traditional